but like Paul said we don't really
there's always going to be exceptions to
the rule but the reality is it doesn't
work both ways oh listen if a man
feelings for a woman he's with that
woman forever yes he's gonna stick with
her
yeah if a woman if a woman catches
feeling she's gonna chase that man even
though it's a one-night stand but for
man gets feelings then that's his woman
that is his woman simple is that because
man hold men hold access or women are in
control of sex men are in control
relationships correct so again like it's
not it's not fun but it's just like how
the world is like there are double
standards for men and for women we're
different we don't operate the same way
and like guys are repulsed by girls that
have slept around